a new variant means new travel rules
these eurostar passengers among the last
to arrive in the uk without needing a
pre-departure test
if it's for the sake of people and to
save people's life we'll do it i think
it's expensive it's not difficult but
it's expensive i mean i think it's
important if we don't know anything
about the variant so far so i would be
happy if we had to take the test
if travelers were relaxed about testing
the battered travel industry is not we
may have seen these kinds of tests
before but this is an industry having
this landed on them on a saturday
evening and it's the second time in a
week that there's been major changes to
travel introduced on a saturday evening
as well this is an industry which lost
roughly 90 percent of its income during
the peak of the pandemic so it's a
sector that doesn't have a lot of money
to fall back on when it then gets a
knock like this
the justice secretary defended the move
despite a 50 increase in new omicron
cases in 24 hours taking the total to
246 and suggesting it's already too late
we are taking the measures and we've
seen that with travel and i know some
people will feel uh overburdened by that
to say look we are going to prevent
the variance omicron and others coming
in
and what's called reseeding uh in the uk
because we
we've got to make sure that we bank the
progress that we've made go into
christmas have a great christmas and go
into the new year
bouncing back
whatever ministers say people will make
their own minds up about what's safe so
public confidence in public health
measures is crucial
britain has the most liberal coveted
regime in western europe the hope is
that maintaining social freedoms will
deliver some christmas cheer as well as
economic recovery these shoppers might
have to pop on a mask if they go in a
store or on the tube but the central
message is trust the vaccines and carry
on
we'll only know if that's right when key
questions about omicron are answered but
its timing could not be worse there's so
much we don't know and when we don't
know it's better to be safe than sorry
now what exactly what that means is
another matter and this is a terror just
like last year with the alpha variant
this is a terrible time for a variant to
come along
when it's probably the next two weeks
are probably some of the highest risk um
periods with a lot of indoor socializing
the new rules will apply from tuesday
but they'll only slow down not stop an
unwelcome arrival it's already here paul
kelso sky news